un baroud d'honneur pour ses
contestataires avant l'instauration du
pass vaccinale ce samedi pas moins de
quatre manifestations ont eu lieu
partout dans la capitale parmi elle est
celle à l'appel du mouvement les
patriotes emmené par florian philippot
qui a rassemblé plusieurs centaines de
personnes place de barcelone dans le 16e
arrondissement
on condamne les violences évidemment
mais on connaît surtout la violence de
monsieur macron contre les français et
qui les met à la rue qui les empêche
d'avoir des droits qui les empêchent de
vivre qui les emmerdes comme il le dit
et qu'il les traite comme des
sous-citoyens ça pour moi ça me paraît
infiniment plus violent que les
quolibets malheureux contre des
journalistes plus tôt dans la journée
les gilets jaunes avaient appelé à un
rassemblement square d'anvers direction
place de la nation un rassemblement où
l'on a pu apercevoir plusieurs figures
du mouvement il y apposant
impasse vaccinale qui portent atteinte
aux libertés publiques à la liberté de
travail et la liberté de circuler donc
c'est complètement à contre-courant de
ce qui se veut en fait au niveau de
l'europe en ce moment mais sur un pass
vaccinale qui va comme l'a prévu macro
emmerder un maximum de français et pas
que des noms vacciner parce qu'il ya des
vaccinés qui vont se retrouver dans le
carcan aujourd'hui des noms vacciner
parce qu'ils n'auront pas fait leurs
boosters et vont se retrouver le bec
dans l'eau et ne vont pas pouvoir
accéder à des services à du cinéma à des
musées ou tout autre chose en france
c'est quand même regrettable de voir un
pays comme la france mère patrie des
droits de l'homme qui aujourd'hui se
couche devant abbasse vaccinale
simplement pour que certains puissent
prendre un café debout une instauration
entérinée par le conseil constitutionnel
ce vendredi une semaine après l'adoption
du texte en deuxième lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
ce lundi il faudra donc présenté un pass
vaccinale pour accéder à des lieux de
loisirs aller au restaurant au grand
rassemblement ou encore emprunter les
transports publics inter régionaux c'est
le conseil constitutionnel avait validé
le projet de loi il avait aussi censuré
la possibilité pour les organisateurs de
réunions politiques de demander un
passing terre un choix fort à 90 jours
de l'élection présidentielle